because things like Jack Welch and
layoffs have become so normalized young
people have grown up in a capitalist
system where they watch their parents
lose their jobs through no fault of
their own it's not a meritocracy you
worked for a company for 20 years you
did good work sorry nothing personal
it's just business we missed our numbers
so they've watched it happen they've
watched the company not take care of
their parents and they've been raised
not to trust companies and so they come
in inherently cynical and inherently
expecting that the company would happily
use their job to help itself and then
stupidly demand loyalty back I don't
blame them the company sets the rules of
the game the people are just playing by
the rules the company set which is no
loyalty at the end of the day great
organizations that are well-led have no
problem with young people leaving every
year so I don't think it's a new reality
I think it is a condition of a broken
capitalism